[Music]
okay so I sort of reversed the order a
little bit and I want to do something
that's probably more new to most most
people and then do something more
familiar later on the next lecture this
later is only the next lecture right so
we want to show that I want to show that
you can find low-rank approximation to a
matrix from just having a length squared
sample right just like we did
multiplication we lose multiplication
again we keep using that and we did
compression right so just like that we
can do SVD or low-rank approximation as
well so we saw that SVD is that way to
do the best low-rank approximation right
that's a what you get out of a sweetie
you truncate it you get the best
possible approximation of every rank we
won't shoot for the best possible
approximation we can't do that because
we are only going to sample we'll shoot
for a good lowering approximation good
in a sense will relate to the best in
comparison to the best it's not too bad
that's what we want to show the
advantage will be the time will be much
it'll be much faster you'll have to do
essentially SVD on a very small matrix
and from that you'll get everything so
that's the advantage by the way one
thing I did not say is length quick
sampling can be applied to infinite
matrices as well I didn't go into that
much so you have infinitely many columns
but of course you have to have a
converging sum of squares otherwise you
can't do it then you can sample a finite
set the infinite number of columns but
finite dimensional you can sample a
finite set and all of this goes true but
we didn't see that so there's another
advantage of doing this as opposed to
full SVD because if it's infinite then
full SVD is impossible right
okay so SVD so again I'm just repeating
this SVD is the best approximation of
each rank what we will show is that if I
pick a length squared sample of just
rolls of a and I do SVD and are just on
that matrix that looks like that that
gives you a decent approximation to
there sweetie
we now have to be little careful a is
the dimensions are different right so
you have to relate there sweetie of our
to the SPD of a in a nice way
we'll see that so
in fact most of the central result here
will not be anything to do with length
squared sampling at all it'll have to be
it's a purely matrix perturbation result
and we'll prove the following if I get a
good low-rank approximation of are
provided R transpose R and a transpose a
or close now just nice to recall the
dimensions of those so a is if a is n by
D a transpose a is d by D and so is R
transpose R are only some number of
rules have been picked so it's little R
by D but our transpose R is also D by D
right and maybe again just a picture so
if I have this as my a the rules are
sample only a few rows a transpose a
wants to take the dot product between
every pair of columns right and our
transpose R just takes the dot product
of the example in the sample rows I mean
just just writing a picture of it so
they are the same dimension so it makes
sense to say that they be roughly equal
and what we will actually show is the
following again the dimensions are
different so the relation will be this
if I restrict a as a linear
transformation to the space-time by the
top view right singular vectors of our
that's a good enough approximation to
ache now that's the right dimensions
right the right-hand side dimension of
ours is right okay this is what we'll
show so the main result really doesn't
have to do with length squared something
it just has to do again with this I have
in a way i perturbed a you can think of
it as a perturbed a transpose a to get a
slightly different major
so R transpose R except it's a lot
simpler because it's a product of two
matrices which are smaller if the
perturbation is not bad then this is
true will prove that okay and then
additionally again purely a metric for
division results there's no probability
involved in that part but as we saw we
will see again we'll recap that if I
have a length squared sampled R then a
transpose a equals R transpose R roughly
approximately and that's familiar matrix
multiplication theorem so if I were
multiplying the matrix a transpose where
the matrix a I might do that
by picking some columns of a transpose
which are rows away and that's my R
transpose and then pick the same same
rows this a which is all ok and matrix
multiplication theorem in spirit I mean
we'll quantify this
it's very told as these are roughly
equal and this perturbation result is
going to tell us if these are roughly
equal then in fact SVD of R will give us
a 3d evade now
let's recall that are itself
I want them up here I want the right
singular vectors of our R is the right
dimension is very high right because R
is like this this dimension is still d
so that seems to be a d dimensional
problem but observe that R is only R by
D I could take RR transpose okay that's
a small matrix there's a little R by
little R matrix that's got only this
many rows in this many columns I can do
I can find it right singular vectors of
are now and say the left singular
vectors can be found from this these are
just eigenvectors of RR transpose we saw
that the spectral decomposition of our
our transpose is related to the singular
value decomposition of our so the left
singular vectors they can be found and
then you find the right thing
the vectors by folding them in right so
we saw that we saw that if I take a
matrix a and multiply on this side by
the right singular vectors I get the
left single bit and vice-versa so I want
you know I have to do I just the
essential computation I have to do that
answers the question is that I have to
find spectral decomposition of very
small matrix okay but then I have to do
some matrix vector multiplications those
are simpler okay this is the gist of the
story so first I'm going to prove the
matrix perturbation result and I will do
a self-contained proof that it that will
involve some classical result which
we'll go over so singular values in
single but here's another point that'll
be nice to make which is important point
from linear algebra right so this is
also something standard but I want to
make this point the perturbation
inequality we'll use is called the
Hoffman Villalon inequality which will
say that if if R transpose R is close to
a transpose a in Frobenius norm then the
singular values are a in our or closed
will prove that okay so I've made a
small perturbation you can think of of a
transpose a to get our transpose R if
the perturbation is small enough the
singular values don't deviate too much
okay that sounds very possible and true
and it's like it's true so now you can
ask what about singular vectors right so
we really want a low-rank approximation
of a and that would be possible
intuitively if we get a good approximate
top singular vectors rate right if I get
the top few singular vectors may not be
exactly but approximately that should be
good enough to get a good lowering
approximation of a if I get them exactly
I get the expect possible forget them
approximately I should get it
approximately now if my inequality here
Haughton belong to any other
quality actually guaranteed with the top
swing of the vectors of RNA of clothes
so if this is small would imply that RNA
have very close singular vectors then it
will be very simple right then that
would say find the single vectors of are
they are close to singular vectors of a
and they give me a good low-rank
approximation yeah unfortunately that's
false this is false right
even though perturbations don't change
singular values too much
they can't completely change singular
vectors okay singular vectors are
singular that's what made one reason to
call them single but singular values are
not so multiple singular vectors are
points of discontinuity of singular
vectors sorry multiple singular values
that means you know it'll like multiply
again value there are many eigen vectors
corresponding to the same eigenvalue
then is called a multiple eigenvalue
here the multiple roots of the
polynomial right similarly if you have a
singular value that has associated with
many singular vectors then there's a
discontinuity I'll elaborate but I'll
give you an example first but before all
that please do recall from linear
algebra that if you had twice for same
eigen values you're a bunch of eigen
vectors they form an invariant subspace
and I could have chosen in linear
algebra right I'll choose any basis of
the subspace can be my eigen vectors and
that's the reason for the discontinuity
right so if you flip things a little bit
you might flip from one basis to another
and so that's a complete flip of the
eigen vectors so and in the simplest
example is this right so if I have a
matrix 1 plus epsilon 1 minus epsilon 0
0 at epsilon equals 0 there's a
discontinuity of the singular vectors
not of the singular values or of the
eigenvectors but not a tagging value
eigen values continuous at x 1 equals
they all right so it's the eigenvector
that's just continuous because if
epsilon is positive the eigenvector is
the first unit directives long is
negative it's a second second unit
vector so it flips completely right so
but you know this the point to remember
is that
low-rank approximation intuitively is
not discontinuous right if I take the
singular vector of a slightly worse
singular value so suppose I had this
picture and epsilon was positive right
so the eigen vector or the singular
vector is the top one but this is a
close by I convector with eigenvalue 1
minus epsilon store 1 plus Epsilon so if
I took this vector instead of that
intuitively I shouldn't be very far off
right in the approximations I get that
is true I am badly off if I want exact
eigenvalues if I want ax equals lambda X
I am not going to get it if I took
business for that right but I'm okay if
I want just an approximation so that's
what we will use so presumably this
point is clear I'm just recapping you
know jogging your memory on linear
algebra what continuity of eigen values
eigen values a continuous eigenvectors
or not now this is just for your
information I won't prove this in fact
it is true that at points of continuity
at points where this discontinuity does
not occur I can victors or singular
vectors also behave nicely okay so these
are harder theorems so when there is a
good gap in singular value so this
continuity occurred when two singular
values were the same okay preventing
that means singular values are quite
different so if there's a gap between
successive singular values then it's
also true that the singular vectors
behave nicely continuously in a
quantified way so not only continuous
but Lipschitz right that's what this is
saying singular vectors of a perturbed
matrix are close to singular vectors are
unperturbed these are harder theorems
sorry sighing TV so called D so these
are called the sine theta theorems or
variance theorems they are due to that
in the simplest versions or due to Kong
and they call the sine theta theorem if
you want to look it up you can do that
yeah again I won't
we don't need that right so we saw that
this this says I don't need these
theorems because low-rank approximation
I'm okay by if I missed I'll buy a
little bit to singular value okay so
just a technical fact this is just a
definition of the restriction of a
linear operator or this linear
transformation to a space so if you have
subspace V spanned by this basis and I
want to take a linear transformation a
restricted to a the six - V I say it's
the restriction of a bar which is that
it's restriction in the sense that a bar
X is the same as a X if X belongs to V +
0 if X is orthogonal to V right and both
are quite clear I mean the 0 is
completely clear if X is orthogonal to
the space wheats orthogonal to all these
W so it's 0 and the first one is just a
little manipulation right
so we have a bar X now X belongs to the
space so X can itself be written as sum
of alpha twt and then you write you
expand out a bar and you get we've done
things like this before
times this quantity right I'm going to
put a t prime here alpha T prime WT
prime and you see that these are all 0
unless T equals T Prime so those terms
go away and only the terms that W 2
remains so then you just get alpha twt
and that's equal to X ok so restriction
just means it does what it does in the
subspace orthogonal just zeros are
orthogonal also in other space ok now
the statement of the main theorem so
we'll state the main theorem which is as
I said purely a matrix perturbation
result and then we'll prove it so now
our is not necessarily length squared
sample is just
any matrix which is R by n it is not
even a sub matrix necessarily right R
has no relation to a so this for every
pair of matrices are n a this applies as
long as says the N is the same right so
if V 1 through we K or the top K right
singular vectors of are so I want to say
if I found the right singular vectors of
R that gives me a good approximation to
eight okay then the assertion is
conclusion is the restriction of a to
the span of this is approximately a in
both Frobenius and spectral long of
course that won't be true for all our
art can be arbitrary but the error
involves how different our is from a in
this sense and here's a precise
statement to precise statements so
spectral and Frobenius norm so let's go
over these so I should say that so I
take a this from the last slide is the
restriction is that thing is a
restriction of the a to the span of that
that's written verbally right this is in
symbols that's what the last light said
right in for vinius from that's less
than or equal to a minus a k4 vinius
norm squared not a K I'm sorry I used
two slightly different notation last
time I said a sub K but this is this is
also just the best rank approximation to
a which we saw last lecture obtained by
a SVD right so the best you can do you
cannot do better than that right you'll
be worse by a little bit and a little
bit is root K times the Frobenius norm
of that so just make sure the scales
balance I take the square of the
fermions norm of a and this is like the
square right I have taken a transpose a
so the dimensions balance right just
so that's statement number one I'm also
in spectral norm this is the best
possible because again SVD was the best
you could do in spectral long and the
error does not have a root K does it has
just the spectral mom they're also not
for Venus perspectival so both of these
spectral malls in this case
so again this is repeating what I said a
- a K squared is the best possible error
over the exact SVD we cannot beat that
that's the best we can do right and this
says second term is is the error that's
a little bit more and we get that now
one note I should have said perhaps that
I should put on the slide maybe but I
can tell you
so more recent theorems but these are
based on sampling actually can give you
the right-hand side which is better
so so these are called
relative error approximation because so
a minus akk right if you were going to
use principal component analysis for
instance this would be hopefully very
small so you would use it for matrices
which are very close to being ranking
okay so if this is very small this may
be actually much bigger so this error
term is pretty big if you did length
square sampling there are more
complicated sampling schemes for which
you can actually show these things which
are called relative error bounds because
the error is relative and so I have a
survey people in which I also have these
things but we'll only prove this right
we only prove with this absolute error I
can give you a references to this so
again this is the this is how far you're
worse off then the best you can do now
one thing that's instructive before we
leave the statement of the theorem and
go to the proof is this theorem is also
true for any R it's true in particular
for R equals zero then it will be nice
to see what they say to us what does R
equals zero say that means I pick no
rows you know in are either
probabilistically other way I pick no
rows so R transpose R is zero right so
this is zero and there's no V's so this
is also zero so you get a squared right
and oh I should have said excuse me so I
should have said no I'm sorry this is
true for all K so I could back off a
minute so if R is zero then there's no
singular vector all of these are zero so
you get a F squared here you get a F
squared plus a little bit more this is
positive right so that's okay there's
any it's not saying very much you don't
expect you to say
what about our equals n that's also an
interesting case or oh it's an oh I
meant to say R equals D I meant to say
all the rows so R equals the total
number of rows array what I mean what's
a possible R then a possible R is all of
a so if all is all of a this is zero and
this is zero right
so still we're just saying 0 less than
or equal to that I'm just saying these
things to as a sanity check if R equals
zero and then it's still true but they
won't be saying anything interesting
it's for other values of R that you
expect this the proof will use the
Hofmann vido inequality which I'll prove
first as I'm going to spend a little bit
of time proving that the many proofs of
that and this I think is one of the
simplest we'll have to do a little bit
of combinatorics here but we'll prove
that and then I'll go back to proving
this okay so the model the story is for
any R you get a decent approximation
spectral and Frobenius norm okay so for
this I need some technical results for
the hoffman we learn inequality so you
have to set of real numbers a 1 to a and
b want to be in these are going to be
singular values of the two matrices but
later right now they're just real
numbers and the A's are in decreasing
order
then the assertion is the permutation
that minimizes the difference between AI
and the be at the per muted spot so I'm
allowed to permute B in any way and I
want to minimize this right so
intuitively it's obvious that the best I
should be able to do to minimize that is
also bringing B's in decreasing order
because A's are in decreasing order if
these are also in decreasing order you
would expect that to be minimized right
so usually the proofs of these are all
very simple and here is the proof
usually first such a statement this
statement is if B was not in decreasing
order so let's say the I plus first
if they are not in decreasing order
there must be adjacent ones which are in
bad order right if B was not sorted
there's a pair that's adjacent not
sorted so you have that and if you just
swap you then prove so you can check
that so it's just a simple check now we
have to use another nice theorem called
birkhoff's theorem that says every
doubly stochastic matrix can be written
as a convex combination of permutation
matrices now i didn't define those terms
so maybe I should just recall the
strengths so doubly stochastic means
non-negative entries all row and column
sums or a 1 all of them so matrix with
this property is called doubly
stochastic and square also I should say
yes doesn't follow and then the term
permutation matrix just means what you
know it's permutation matrix this just
got one one permutation matrix this is a
permutation right so I fi equals 1 for
some permutation F I should say this
there exists a permutation F so I said
this is 1 and equal to 0 for all other
entries
it's the Dynel matrix or any permutation
there are lot of pain factorial right so
back off services every doubly
stochastic matrix can be written as a
convex combination of permutation matrix
I won't prove that but I just assumed
that
so when AI and bi now or both in
decreasing order according to this write
the minimum value of this quantity AI
minus bi squared sorry
AI minus B J squared X IJ I'm going to
try to minimize that over all X's which
are doubly stochastic former doubly
stochastic matrix right is attained at
the permutation matrix first so why is
that why is the minimum attained at a
permutation matrix because the convex
combination right so if the minimum is
attained at some doubly stochastic
matrix you can always write it as a
convex combination of permutation
matrices and there's a linear function
in the X IJ so it should be attained at
one of the permutation matrices and
secondly since the identity permutation
is the men over all permutations this is
attained by the identity right so we saw
that the permutation that minimizes is
the identity that was this part and this
says that over all so kassig matrices
the minimum of the tentative permutation
matrix must be the identity so we'll
come back we'll recur uses the next
slide but I may have to come back and
recall this for you so now often we
don't know okay I guess I don't have it
I have it all displayed one shot this is
the proof of Hoffmann be long now that
we have all that so if you have two real
symmetric matrices with lambdas are the
eigenvalues I've arranged lambdas or
both matrices in decreasing in non
increasing order then the assertion is
the lambdas are closed right provided P
and Q are closed so if P and Q are
closed the lambdas are closed right the
eigenvalues are closed again this is
continuity of eigenvalues eigenvectors
are not continuous so you take the sum
of squares of all these things that's
less than or equal to the Frobenius norm
the difference between P and Q so how do
we prove that
so I'm going to go but I mean this while
going over this will recap some linear
algebra as we go walk so I'm going to
write P as udu transpose and this is V D
prime V transpose
these are spectral decomposition x' and
just recall so you columns of U or eigen
vectors of P the P and Q are symmetric
right eigenvectors a P so they have
spectral decomposition here right so and
V is columns of V or the eigenvectors of
Q and you so we have been using a
slightly different notation but you D D
is diagonal DT prime or diagnose they
are the eigenvalues so UT u transpose if
you think about it is the same as saying
lambda this is for P lambda I a P you
column I of U so call um I of you I
wrote it this way before and that is Rho
I of you
I'm just expanding the matrix this is
just a matrix notation which we haven't
used before but more standard then the
monitoring we've been using right so
this this is just outer product of
columns and rows they sum up it's worth
checking that they are these are the
same and these diagonals so it just
comes like that now what we know is that
the columns the eigenvectors are
orthogonal the columns of u and v u or
orthogonal or orthonormal and a matrix
notation that is just going to say that
uu transpose now sorry i asked me to say
u transpose U is the identity and V
transpose V is also the identity
actually are the other way as well
because if you have a full dimensional
orthonormal matrix then the rows are
also see if you have in n space you have
n columns which Auto normal the matrix
also have Auto normal rows not true if
it's less than n but if it's in that's
true so in fact uu transpose is also
equal to V V transpose V good right okay
once you've linear algebra we'll recap
and we'll use that okay so the so these
are spectral decomposition that
eigenvalues arranged in non decreasing
order in both cases and I'm going to do
something that it looks you know it's
it's pulled out of the Hat so I'm going
to take P minus Q multiplied by u
transpose and V on the two sides I get
you I'm just expanding this out u
transpose u D and so on so for that I
get that now u transpose use the
identity right it's one of these things
so that goes away again D times u
transpose V and again V transpose V is
identity that goes away you get that now
these are Auto normal things so they are
all length preserving they don't change
the Frobenius norm it's invariant for
variance norm under these transformation
so I get this is just
I'm taking the Frobenius norm of the
whole thing here square ad that's the
same as P minus Q squared and that's the
same as that lavinia small squid and
that's the expanded version of this now
why is just quick check that that is
correct that's just algebra but let's
check that
so I want I want to know what the IJ
entry of this is right well I get entry
of this is di I won some over I won u
transpose i1 i2 I'm just writing them
down and vi2 J right sum over i won i J
I want better be equal to I otherwise
it's zero so this goes away this is I
and so you get di is just I call that di
and this is just u transpose V IJ entry
because I sum over I to this sum over I
2 goes in there and they get back so
that I've just done the algebra for the
first one right and this is just your
same so anyway so you get that now u
transpose V is also orthonormal because
U and V are you have to check that
another linear algebra fact maybe I
won't check that they are all and so the
rows and columns column sums of the
matrix rows and column sums column
lengths are 1 that means the sum of
squares is 1 so if I take this matrix
that is doubly stochastic right so I put
this then I use the theorem from the
last slide right so this so di minus di
prime squared these are eigen value
differences squared there's something
that I want there that's what I want
right
those are weighted by a doubly
stochastic matrix and the minimum is
attained when I put the identity there
that's what I showed in the last slide
right so I put the identity so only the
cross terms go away I and J not equal go
away so you just said I in I and I for
both B and D Prime and you get that you
do have to check
all the all the intermediate steps so
this is that quantity right and they
started from that I started from that
side okay so that's Hoffman V naught and
let's go onto our tail okay so we want
to be K so now we have to do a little
bit of algebraic manipulation
unfortunately to get to the theorem but
it's not too bad I hope so we compute we
take V 1 to V K so the theorem said I'm
going to restrict a to the space spanned
by the top K I singular vectors of R so
these are the top k singular vectors I'm
gonna make a full basis out of it right
you can always complete a basis so I
would like to prove this is small so
this is a restriction to this I like to
prove this is small and I'm going to
pull something out of the Hat I'm going
to pull this out of the Hat and subtract
so again unfortunately this you'll have
to go through some manipulation here in
fact I wanted to prove this is small
with respect to this right so maybe I
should go back to the theorem for a
minute yeah so I want to prove this is
small comparison I just brought this
over to this side so I've taken this
minus that I want to show that small
so I have that and I'm going to expand
that okay so this a few more lines of
proof so this is a this is a restricted
to a particular subspace okay and that's
always the four vania some of that
difference is a minor side you have to
prove that right but I mean a simple
proof of that is just by the completion
of the basis so okay maybe I should I
should I should write that so AF squid
is just equal to a times so the for
Venus from squid is the sum of the rows
great lengths and you can write the
matrix non nice norms are always
invariant whatever the basis so I choose
VT as the basis then you'll get this and
I've subtracted out the first case so
you get only k plus 1/2 what's left
right so that minus that you also have
to prove that that is equal to that
again similar proof I won't do that
these two cancel out and you get that
minus that so that I have to prove a
small few more tricks
so a K is the best rank approximation so
that came from SVD so that that's just a
sweetie theorem we proved we proved that
SV is the best approximation so you get
that what about this you can see that
that's just equal to AV T squared right
you see all of this is not true if it's
not all to normal everything uses all
these facts so that's true so now I want
to write that as equal to this is the
same as what I had before
here's another trick I'm going to take a
VT squared that is I mean the first here
is not a trick it's just simple that's
just equal to VT transpose a transpose
there's a length squared of a vector
that's equal to its dot product with
itself again that's not a trick
but I'm going to add our transpose R and
subtract it okay that's okay I'm adding
and subtracting I've done this several
times I did it last time too and now
what do we get now we get this is this
grade here VT or the singular vectors of
our so those are just the singular
values of R so that's a difference okay
so I'm going to use this difference and
bound it using hoffman we don't I'm
coming to that but that's this term in
this term I still have to deal with this
term that I've rewritten that I have not
dealt with it yet so now this is less
than or equal to K times that because
for each vector V this quantity is that
most respected law of that now we define
spectrum or slightly differently but yet
we defined spectral norm away as the max
over all we obey V but it's also true
that the spectral norm of a of a
symmetric matrix a transpose a minus R
transpose R this is Smith this is
symmetric they both so it's difference
is symmetric for a symmetric matrix the
spectral norm is the max over all three
of V transpose times of need x times V
okay this all at the end of the stages
gave me a K but I want to get a root
kick it's you're happy with K you're
done so I'm going to work a little bit
one more slate of work to get a root key
so for this we have to use
cauchy-schwarz so we take that the
reason I'm doing this proof is partly
its algebra is uninteresting but
hopefully it'll jog your memory on the
linear algebra that you know you might
have forgotten so so for this we use
Cauchy Schwartz to assert that that is
less than or equal to that that's just a
sum of K real numbers these are real
numbers
so that's personally somewhat squared
and square root and then a root K at the
top now what is this so this is so I
claim that that's at most of a vinius
norm why is that the phoniness norm is
invariant in a change of basis so in the
wheat VT basis right these entries or
the diagonal entries of that matrix so
we have matrix a transpose a minus R
transpose R if diagonal entries in that
basis or justice I'm taking the sum of
squares of the diagonal entries which is
at most of a vinius norm I'm throwing
away something cause off diagonal is not
being counted so that you get that okay
okay we are still to bound that for that
we use hoffman v lot so by the way open
V naught is only for symmetric matrices
as stated so I have to do some of these
missions to get to the proper symmetric
matrix so we use another coffee Schwarz
and then plugging all this and you get
the first you get the Frobenius novel
solution turns out the spectral norm
proof is not much harder in this case in
the yesterday it was harder but today
it's not so bad
pounding the spectral mom so we have
only a couple more things learning a
spectral norm for the second assertion
that's a spectral norm assertion that's
all the top singular value you of this
must be orthogonal to the span of this
we went through VK so because I
subtracted out the action of V 1 through
BK if you had a component along this it
would make just 0 right so that's not
interesting so you might as well be
assumed to your formal to this so this
product goes away and you just with or
left with a u so so again we do have to
do some work so this is what I wanted to
bound so again this is a this is the
restriction of a to that subspace I want
to say the difference is small I'm since
the top single value of U singular
vector is U so I get that I get that now
this trick again I have a transpose a
I'm going to add and subtract our
transpose or it's same trick and that's
because I know how to bound this that's
this and this quantity U was orthogonal
to the top K singular values and so
singular vectors of are these are the
exact singular vectors of our it's the
top K so this is at most K plus 1 so we
again saw that so I it lives in the
space of the k plus 1 and later singular
vectors therefore you get the best that
okay so we're not done yet so that's
that same written like that now I have
that I'm adding and subtracting Sigma K
plus 1 squared a this is we know what
this is how about this so I'm going to
say that's also at most this ok and that
is using wise inequality
so let's remember that again will I read
a short proof of this this is one of the
many inequalities in algebra but also it
says for a symmetric matrix like RR
transpose R is I take the k plus first
or any eigenvalue in decreasing order I
can refer on decreasing order that is at
most I've written in a particular way
let's write as inequality here
so it's saying lambda k plus 1 R
transpose R yes for instance less than
or equal to lambda k plus 1 for
different matrix a transpose a plus I've
written that so that's that's I would
like to say this is a top eigenvalue of
that but it's the top eigenvalue and
absolute value right so so that is that
site and there's a symmetric inequality
how do you prove something like this so
we prove it by taking well we have to
use min max theorem so I guess I didn't
I didn't right okay so we don't prove it
well you can look up a proof to prove
this I have to use min max theorems
which I just realized I didn't prove but
you know you can look up any standard
book and you'll have this inequality I
do I do have to have symmetric matrices
right otherwise I'd be a little more
careful but here we do and that is
telling us type this difference that's
this minus side right the difference
between these two is bounded by this
Sigma so that's got a factor of 2 plus
Sigma K square this thing 1 k plus 1
split okay so that's the end of that
story for of proving the main theorem
and by length squared sampling we are we
can get an hour we can get it by any
other means right as long as this is
small for which it's enough to do this
video on that
you know I want to take a step back and
figure out what we have done in terms of
time how much we have saved right okay
so this will also recap the overall
proof and sort of the algorithm behind
it so what we needed was the right
singular vectors of a smaller matrix R
and for that we can do SVD IRA marked on
this first in the beginning but I want
to recap it because now we have an
algorithm and we will real analyze the
running time we can do SVD of RR
transpose which is a small matrix r by r
matrix and that gives us the left
singular vectors of R so the eigenvalues
of this or the left singular vectors of
R because you know it goes on the left
of R or the right of our transpose same
as left to R from which we get the right
singular vectors by just multiplying
once they are I'm going to figure out
how much time all this going to take
right that's that's the story so this
how just meant multiplying left singular
vectors they are to get the right
singular vectors so we pick our rows now
I'm going to give you a length squared
sampling version you could do it better
means again pick our rules away by
length squared sampling scale them so
that for the resulting matrix expected
value of R transpose R is a transpose a
remember this is going back to the
beginning when we did length squared
sampling we said to make it unbiased you
have to scale it so you pick these rows
right and to make the estimator unbiased
you had to scale it by the you have to
scale down by the probability you picked
so unbiased just means the expected
values right we already did this in the
beginning now find our R transpose so I
picked our the expected value R
transpose R is a transpose a but I but I
find our friends but I find the other
thing RR transpose finally left single
vector by spectral decomposition pre
multiply or by the listening the vector
to get the right singular vectors of are
all that is routine
and then you return a times this as the
implicit LRA
meaning if I don't really want
explicitly what the low-rank
approximation is and that is useful
sometimes I'll try to show you one
instance where it's useful you do a
times V T V T transpose or if you want
an explicit one multiply out under turn
at the time required if you okay I
should mention one thing I didn't we
didn't do many algorithms here but if a
matrix is sparse lots of big matrices
have very few non zeros and you don't
write down all the entries of the matrix
you only write down a linked list of non
zeros so that's a general trick maybe I
should write that so a sparse matrix we
have few non zeros one example is the
hypertext link matrix of the web so it
has X billion right matrix right but
each row is only about ten non zeros
so you write it down by having basically
a linked list of non-zeros
linked lists of nonzero entries it just
shows you where the next to increase and
so on so you don't write down the zeros
you basically have space proportional
your space which is order here's a piece
of notation that's now become standard
and inside of a which is the number of
non-zeros
of a number of non-zeros so in fact
several I didn't mention many algorithms
but there's been some effort and people
have now made many of these algorithms
depend fairly benignly linear quite
often on the number of non zero only so
in the case of web matrix right if you
add an N squared algorithm that'll be
pretty bad but there aren't any squared
entries to be read so the argument is
that this can all be done in time
proportional to the number of non-zeros
provided the are and all the constant so
one way to see that that so this is the
advantage of sampling algorithms by the
way over iterative methods or any of
these methods australian-american
algebra methods
unless you're careful will fill out non
zeros the matrix will become dense and
then very after a few iterations and
then you're in trouble
so these don't happen with these kinds
of sampling based algorithms just
because you work only on a sample of the
matrix so if P is the maximum number of
nonzero entries in any row in this case
P is 10 now it's not true that the
maximum number is 10 but pretend there
was the average then it would be 10 so
the first step can be done in two pauses
from external memory so we saw that how
to sample going through the matrix twice
from external memory
right you compute the probabilities one
step and the next step to pick them out
then you find our our transpose and now
our our transpose is our rose x our
arrows so our squid multiplications but
each only P time make the only P knowns
eros dot product of two vectors with
pinions it was only it takes P time
spectral decomposition can be done in R
cubed time or better our is to be
thought of as a constant right and P is
that so multiplying the K left single
effect vectors of our so this gives you
the left singular vectors are the right
singular vectors can be found in time K
times R times P so you do take time
dependent on n for reading through the
entire matrix but after that the times
or not right unless you want to do this
multiplication then you have to go to
the whole matrix once more so roughly
the time is linear in the number of
non-zeros
and that's typical we didn't do this
kind of analysis before whether it's
typical of these sampling methods now I
want to do one more slide and then tell
you something we had which I didn't put
on the slide so I mentioned in passing
earlier on write SVD requires only finds
the best fit line through the origin
right subspace is always possible origin
it only finds subspaces through the
origin okay now you could have data
which is nowhere near the origin and
then this is a big restriction
so here's the origin and you all your
data could be here and the best-fit line
might be like this but you might end up
finding this right so you don't want to
do that how do you avoid doing that so
so I first redefinition a find space of
dimension K is just a translation of a
k-dimensional space translation just
means so this is a vector space v V Plus
X translation just means the set of you
plus X you belong I mean it's just
moving like that if it's also a pentacle
translation this is like it just moves
of that space it's also true that this
next also it's a good you can translate
this way this vector of this vector you
get the same thing all that matters is
what the perpendicular component is okay
that's just a definition right that's
called affine space so the lemma I want
to prove which is fairly simple is the
best fit of fine dimensional a fine
space of any dimension passes through
the centroid of the data the centroid of
the data you have data points a 1 3 n
centroid C is just what you think it is
these are vectors it's just average
right average is going to mean component
wise average just add them up as vectors
and divide by the total number okay so
the proof is that if it's not the case
if you had a best at subspace with in
pass through the origin it's a
contradiction you're going to gain by
translating it to contain zero
so first let's prove this so suppose
here real numbers a 1 2 en and I want to
choose an X to minimize sum of squared
distances of AI it's not difficult to
see that the centroid is the right I
mean this also comes up in you know
defining variance from mean and sorry so
proof okay so let's quickly go with the
proof of this
proof that's used in many places so I'm
going to expand AI minus X whole squared
so I write it as AI minus C plus C minus
a I'm sorry that's not a this let's see
sorry that's alright C minus X plus X
okay there's a cross term that I omitted
because it's zero right so so there'll
be three terms then I explained the
whole square so I'll also get it term
sum over I equals 1 to N the twice a I
minus x times now a a minus C times C
minus X this is 0 because C minus X
comes out is a constant is independent
of the AI 2 also comes up sum over I
equal so that goes away so you get that
that proves that for the case of real
numbers right because this is a
non-negative quantity and the best value
you can have for it is 0 and 0 means x
equals C that's the lowest value x
equals C that's what we wanted to prove
same thing is true for vectors so I want
to prove this for vectors actually so AI
minus X I want to minimize the sum of
squared distances I'll come back to how
you apply to a sweetie
so I write it as a a minus c plus c
minus x plus i also put the cross term
here cross term is AI minus c dot
product with c minus X right that's dot
product I'm just using the fact that
length squared of vector is dot product
with itself and you know it's sum of two
vectors if you expand it is what you get
and that term is 0 again C minus X comes
out even though it's a vector the sum of
this is zero because some of AI equals C
C is the centroid okay like okay so how
is how this is use for the SVD so if you
want to find the best best line that
fits the data rather than the one going
to the origin you could just as well
find the centroid
okay that's simple enough to do add all
the data points in divide take the
average and then subtract that from each
each data point so practice centroid
from each data point now the centroid
becomes the origin so there's no
restriction in assuming that your
subspace has to pass through the origin
okay say sweetie you find the best
affine space if you did this so for a
bunch of applications you do that so
okay so I think that's all I have on the
slides but I want to close by with take
a few more minutes to say two more
things okay so so far what we saw was
that via matrix a we do row sampling to
get our and we reduced by this process
finding SVD of a to basically SVD of our
we could we further reduced it to our
our transpose but this is in spirit what
we did so you can ask now I can now take
our do column sampling on our and reduce
it to a really small matrix now can
repeat that is I do column sampling
on our to get an hour-by-hour matrix W
I'm intuitive Lee I should be able to
reduce SVD of our to finding sv DFW
right I mean it's just a symmetric
version of that problem except columns
instead of rows so this is true but the
proof is much more complicated and the
trouble happens because things go wrong
when singular values are close to zero
so if somewhere in this process we have
to worry about singular values that are
close to zero so this is true but
complicated I would say actually much
more complicated so it's not but the
moral of the story is by doing the
sampling twice
you finally be left with a constant size
matrix both rows and columns constant
number and that's all that you need to
worry about okay in some sense I mean
there was true when we do our our
transpose the small matrix but we'd have
to find our transpose for that so we
don't have to do any computation on big
matrices except to sample that's what
this is going to tell you now in
practice however I'm not sure this has
been used as much as row sampling has
been used quite a bit but both sides I
think it's too expensive still although
I'm not current on the state-of-the-art
but to do that okay that's one thing I
wanted to say the other thing also I
should've put up on the slides I just
say that
so our error bounds for length squid
sampling always had well generally had
on the right hand side not every one of
them there was one today where I had
only a spectral mom but this is what I
generally had on the right hand side
right and I told you that I cannot
replace this by spectral norm that's
correct but what's true is that can be
replaced by epsilon times Frobenius norm
times the spectral mom so one of the
Frobenius norm can be replaced by
spectral norm now this looks just like
an improvement going to another norm
it's not this is a theorem due to root
ulsan which came about you know maybe
five six years after the original paper
then after paper but this uses a nice
bit of function analysis it's not simple
there are slightly simpler proof of this
but it's still more simple now this
turns out to lead to a bunch of things
probably the most important thing is
graphs falsification
and I'll tell you the result but not
prove anything
this is due to Spielman and Srivastava
so you need you need the fact that one
of the phobia norms has gone through
spectral mom to get grasp falsification
so grasp ossification says the following
I'll give you any graph gve from that I
can produce a graph this is n vertices I
can produce a graph G H which is a sub
graph of G I write it like this so H is
on n log n vertices sorry n log n edges
and has a property that every cut in H
is roughly same as every cut in G so for
any cut s yes the weight of edges across
the cut in H weight of edges across as V
minus s in H is within one plus or minus
epsilon of the same thing in G
so it's a purely graph theory result so
what it's saying is I can produce a much
smaller graph so that there are
exponentially many possible ways of
cutting the graph into two parts right
any subset of vertices any subset of
vertices each without fail for every cut
has about the right number of edges as G
does I mean that's completely
non-trivial and it's quite requires
quite a lot but central to that is
rootlessness theorem about a rule the
same is also about length squared sample
so can we replace this for just likes
wave sampling so this I won't be able to
prove that but hopefully I've stated the
result well enough for you to see so
what is interesting is of course that is
the purely combinatorial result follows
from this this matrix kind of stuff
right it's not terribly surprising a lot
of graph problems are related to
matrices but it does follow the bound
today I showed is also what spectral
norm on the right hand side but the
matrix multiplication bound for instance
had only the Frobenius norm that can be
replaced so okay so maybe I should say
more specifically we wanted to multiply
two matrices a and B a R a transpose
let's say so a ni transpose minus our
estimate even if I wanted to bound the
two norm the right hand side was only
the Frobenius norm what rules and proves
is that for that specific bond side it
was not precise enough for this specific
bound that I want the spectral norm of
my error of the product is bounded by
one Frobenius norm once you still can't
get rid of this it cannot be purely
spectral
the centroid thing is for Frobenius yeah
you're right central thing is not
suspect likely there's some interesting
open questions there but know what
there's only for convenience or if the
rows of a were picked from an iid
distribution right
then you would probably want to send her
out by subtracting the mean the mean is
just the average of the rows a very good
estimate of the mean because you've got
enough samples and you subtract it out
then as we said then a transpose will be
the variance covariance matrix a a
transpose a a transpose will be the
variance covariance matrix so so I think
I mentioned this once the original
motivation for all these sampling
results basically came from trying to
estimate the variance covariance matrix
distribution so you would subtract out
the center there are cases where you
don't want the center data I probably
don't I mean there are some PC examples
where you don't want to Center data but
certainly iid pics you want to set the
data likely yeah sometimes you want to
keep the data and all negative that's
another example non-negative then you
don't want to Center it the theory only
gives you bounds on are that are very
large right and the question is can we
get lucky with smaller our I think there
are empirical studies but I don't know
Oh terrific Lee the epsilon well if you
want an epsilon a point zero one there's
an R which is one over epsilon to the
fourth power or something so that would
be 10 to the 8th you don't necessarily
want I'd tell we begin the whole matrix
but you hope empirically smaller R will
work